it's
[Music]
come for
e
watch don't come in here first of all
and now you're pulling the arm
this
way use the arm like shet see helps him
go
backwards so watch the
hand it
passes through the three levels
get
down
push so I'll just do the
Jo don't start looking for the head
right
away keep the
connection
here manipulate that that
time then the head then he gives the
opening for the head as he's getting
pushed back
turn your
waist don't turn my
this the CL okay not my wayist
that's it
all right if if you look at
your Mo your dojo Mo in the background
is that Crest right Mr
Parker true so yes there's reference to
my Kempo Origins but if we remember he
took that and
modified what he saw in a DS text a
diagram in a one of the oldest DS texts
and in the middle of that symbol is the
heart symbol
um it that that shape is is very very
ancient and very very strange because
people knew what the heart looks like
they were they were Hunters we don't we
don't hunt we don't cut nothing open
like you know we have to use books and
stuff people know what the heart look
like that doesn't look like the heart
okay um so let's just open the door that
it's it's it may reference
cocol like the heart mind right but it's
not a literal drawing of it okay and uh
when we look at that shape in terms of
our iido
tabaki you you have your inward spiral
you see and you reverse it and you have
the the outer spiral and you if you
follow it to the other end there's your
outward spiral okay and so these we know
that this these hand shapes here um
represent a kind of uh Duality that when
combined make up the universe okay so
you have your uh in in Dost circles you
have your your fire and your water and
fire and water are like representative
of Yin and yangong okay so now you're
putting them
together and we know also that our lower
tonen what we're trying to do is undo
move or reverse the doing of Yin and
yangong and to return to the Dow okay um
and so we have our fire or our yangong
and we have our uh water or our Yin
right but you know Earth is Yin too so
you have all these kind of modalities
where you're going to combine Yin and
yangong uh fire water Heaven and Earth
Etc you're going to combine these
dualities and and you're going to
reverse their doing to get back to the
doubt okay and we say in my discourse
that we're going to spiral rotate the
these two aspects when you spiral rotate
them they can't be in the XY dichotomy
relationship dichotomous relationship
and the universe reorders itself it's
just what happens okay so if we look for
example at our Chi dropping exercises
um where you're working by yourself we
know that I'm going to release
everything there can't be tension in my
body I have to let go of the
tension and we have uh movements where
we're
dropping dropping right so we come down
dropping the chi coming around we have
the breathing exercises that chibba
Sensei used to do uh not really knowing
what they're doing you just did them uh
but you can see that you're going to
make that heart shape do you see you're
going to make that heart shape with your
hand and that heart shape is in here uh
we just have to make sure we're doing it
because the heart shape through laong is
going to spir rotate the Heaven and
Earth aspects that are in my uh lower
ton den and that's going to drop my mind
that's going to bring a sensation to the
ego tripartite mind and in that way it
is a moving meditation as long as I
understand meditation energy ically or
it is a moving prayer as long as I
understand prayer as a no self practice
okay so as you're doing this
technique you are working th those
patterns to spiral rotate the lower
tanden through laong okay so that is way
more important than you just throw the
guy okay so as you as you watch me I
have gon which is the outward spiral
it's the beginning of the out spiral but
because I'm on the inside it is
functioning like an inward spiral and
that's part of the undoing of the
dichotomous relationship okay that
you're trying to do so I'm I'm inversing
things do you see that so I come
around one and
yes get
Cheon but as I go under it it's now
jodon you see so I established jodon
without changing anything and and yes
his hand is going up but because I'm
rotating it's he's going backwards on
the hand and so I'm inversing and
reversing to undo these dichotomies okay
so outward spiral acting like inward
spiral a pushing of Chon you see is
bringing him in and Jon which is the up
is bringing him out
and all that's moving in me so I'm I'm
really just doing this I'm just happen
to be turning inside of
it then after the upward you turn back
to get down and the outward
spiral the outward spiral Che on Jo
on get on
I'm feeling it in here and I'm feeling
it what it's doing to my mind
hey
can you see it
now
okay okay so part of the energetics and
because of the concentric relationship
between the energetic field and the
Marshall field is that there's no
tension in my body there's absolutely no
tension in my body which you can feel so
the technique feels light as until
the throwing part
um it's very tempting to start
tensing you see like no that's not right
cuz you won't get your tonden feel you
won't feel that
okay so the technique is very light it's
very light there there's nothing there
there's nothing right but there's enough
to adhere right and there's enough like
he can't he can't push like he can't
push me that way he can't push me that
way see okay and he can't LIF my hand
not you'll feel you'll feel the presence
there you see so but I'm not driving in
tensing and
flexing everything is just working
inside me okay are working inside me the
same thing in this weird
position he can't push at me there's no
tension in my body okay uh as we're
coming around right again he can't he
can't push on it push on it you can't
push on it but there's no tension
there's no tension okay no tension he
can't he can't push down there's no
tension no tension throughout my body
okay and then same thing here you can't
push back there's no tension okay and
there's no tension in this
Ro so just like as you're doing your
either your seated release
drills one of the things that you're
told to scan for first is tension let
everything be
dropable you should feel that your
glutes should
release
uh your spot on your back that I want
you to release it should release your
throat should release uh the shoulders
are not engaged I
never have the desire to throw that's
going to flex me okay everything is just
as if I was by
myself I don't do that exercise like
this
right I'm not going to do the releasing
drill okay
so you can you can start to see
that you know maybe you weren't seen it
before but everything is relaxed
okay but there's power in there you have
to trust it you have to have faith in it
and it'll work okay where's the power
come from it comes
from the internalization of the conflict
this is why there's no true non-c
contestation externally so for example
if he's pushing
me an exter Jal is is here like that see
I got out of the
way but if you pay attention there's
there's a tension in my body and then I
move with
tension but your internal there's no
tension we're not we're not going to
move we're not going to move at no point
can he push into me throughout any of
the cycle he can't push into me but
there's no tension because it's being
internalized okay true non-c
contestation can only happen internally
and that's what is allowing me to stay
relaxed because I don't ever push on
what's pushing on me and so I I don't
need that I just stay relaxed his young
aspect comes into me bounces off the
ground and goes back out of it okay so
you can't
just make this external you're like you
pushed like got out of the way you see
cuz you're going to start tensing right
about here people start tensing right sh
to the throat your
T and that's actually where the the
cycle is more complete okay the cycle is
more complete the cycle is more
complete okay